die signale sind äußerst mysteriös und
bisher haben fachleute noch keine
wirkliche erklärung dafür
um mitternacht herum nämlich pulsiert
das magnetfeld des mars das zeigen daten
der mars mission inside zudem scheinen
die magnetischen aktivitäten des roten
planeten auch stärker zu sein als man
bislang angenommen hat das spannende
nachrichten vom mars kommen in diesen
tagen aber auch vom weltraumroboter
community die zum science fiction gibt
es täglich spannende science videos aber
in den kanal und aktivität locken nur
dann verpasst ihr nichts los geht's
herzlich willkommen schon seit november
2010 ist der stationäre länder
der insight mars mission der nasa auf
dem roten planeten geplant ist das
inside mars beben ist und außerdem
spannende erkenntnisse dazu liefert die
planetare magnetfelder entstehen bei
diesen messungen sind den
verantwortlichen nasa forschungsteam
jetzt äußerst merkwürdige signale
aufgefallen das alles wurde auf einem
treffen des european planetary science
congress und american astronomical
society bekannt gegeben
manchmal nämlich beginnt das magnetfeld
des mars zum pulsieren kurioserweise
beginnt das ganze immer um mitternacht
herum hier konnten wellen aufgezeichnet
werden
die länger als eine minute anhalten das
magnetische phänomen dauert dem ganzen
sogar bis zu zwei stunden
ein ähnliches phänomen kann auch hier
auf der erde gemessen werden
schwankungen des magnetfeldes werden bei
uns beispielsweise durch sonnenwinde
ausgelöst ein farbenfroher nebeneffekt
polarlichter die wir beobachten können
doch warum finden diese bewegungen im
magnetfeld des roten planeten immer um
dieselbe uhrzeit statt warum tauchen die
mysteriösen signale immer gegen
mitternacht auf laut der experten und
expertinnen sind die signale vor allem
in nördlicher richtung sehr stark eine
erklärung für das zeitliche auftreten
der signale gibt es bisher nicht die
auswertung der daten zeigt den
fachleuten zu dem auch dass die mars
größte offensichtlich deutlich
magnetischer ist als man es bisher
angenommen hatte die entsprechenden
geräte wurden von inside nach seiner
landung auf dem mars abgestellt demnach
ist das magnetfeld in der direkten nähe
des länder sogar 20 mal stärker als es
fachleute bisher vermutet hatte
20 mal dazu der us astronom bern in
einem interview
national geographic wir bekommen einen
einblick in die magnetische geschichte
des mars wie noch nie zuvor
das nasa forschungsziele feiert den
erfolg und empfiehlt weitere
detaillierte untersuchung die starke
magnetisierung in den stein zeigt dass
man mit hilfe von magnetometer noch viel
über den dynamiken der größe des mars
lernen kann
wir empfehlen ausdrücklich einen
interdisziplinären ansatz zur
untersuchung der marsoberfläche und es
gibt möglicherweise eine weitere
spektakuläre entdeckung die rede ist von
einer seltsam elektrisch leitenden
schicht die einige kilometer dick ist
und die von dem insight länder unter der
marsoberfläche aufgespürt wurde handelt
es sich hierbei etwa um flüssiges wasser
reine spekulation denn all diese neuen
ergebnisse von inside sind noch nicht
durch die so genannten peer review
prozesse gelaufen hier bei bewährten
unabhängige forscherinnen forscher neue
erkenntnisse aus der wissenschaftswelt
und beurteilen diese objektiv und
weitere spannende erkenntnisse zum roten
planeten liefert in diesen tagen aber
auch der weltraumroboter curiosity der
wohl auf spuren einer oase gestoßen ist
das berichtet jetzt ein nasa
forschungsteam aufgespürt hat denn diese
3,5 milliarden als jahre alten spuren am
sogenannten geld krater deren
durchmesser von 160 kilometern hat
entstanden ist der wohl durch einen
meteoriteneinschlag dieser sorgte dann
dafür dass sich das klima auf dem roten
planeten veränderte die flüsse und seen
in einem einst feucht warmen klima
verwandelten sich in eine karge
wüstenlandschaft dazu der us
wissenschaftler william rappen im gilt
krater ist der wandel des mars auf
einzigartige weise konserviert somit ist
jetzt also klar wie der rote planet vor
etwa 3,5 milliarden jahren ausgesehen
hat wasser war demnach ein zentrales
element auf dem planeten denn der große
geld krater war den neuen erkenntnissen
zufolge aus gefüllt mit wasser eine
wirklich spannende erkenntnisse dazu
will ich da bin
wenn wir verstehen wann und wie sich der
klimawandel auf dem mars vollzogen hat
ist das gleichzeitig ein puzzlestein für
eine andere frage wann und wie lange hat
es mikrobiellen leben auf dem mars
gegeben
finden wir 2021 endlich leben auf dem
mars anklicken also hier anschauen und
neugier zu abonnieren mega kann
erst dieses jahr gestartet bis dann
bleibt dran